we've wrapped up our congressional
district for debate this evening it was
between Democrat incumbent Stephen
Horsford and his Republican Challenger
Sam Peters David charns has the
breakdown of all the topics discussed
Welcome to our congressional district
for debate Democratic Congressman
Stephen Horsford and the man looking to
replace him Republican Sam Peters
couldn't have proven they are more
different my opponent has uh
continuously voted to spend more money
and more money and it's not going to get
better that's why my opponent is Extreme
he's out of touch he does not reflect
the priorities of the people of Nevada's
fourth district Peter is painting
horseford as a member of the democratic
establishment we've seen it again month
after month after month uh 40-year highs
on inflation it's not getting better
Horsford saying Peters is a radical
republican out of touch with reality
this is greed inflation based on Big Oil
big gas companies that are trying to
gouge consumers at a time when we need
to be working to lower cost from
pandemic loans Peters received and
lockdowns how do you justify taking that
loan while also criticizing the spending
so the government shut down small
business across the country shut down
the entire economy for two years
Horsford responded the money that helped
pay Peter's employees came through
bipartisan legislation my opponent
doesn't want to talk about the pandemic
that also was killing lives and
affecting livelihoods on the issue of
abortion Peter says it settled law in
Nevada Horsford attacked him for saying
politicians shouldn't dictate school
policy but Republicans want to pass a
National Abortion ban my opponent is
anti-choice and wants politicians in
Washington to decide what women and
doctors should do I have no desire to
steal Women's Health Care I am married
to a woman I have two daughters there is
no no sensible argument that can be made
to say that I want to steal Women's
Health Care Peters asking voters to
choose him Mr Horsford was right on one
thing the the differences could not be
more Stark as Congressman Horsford seeks
another term the choice could not be
more clear in the decision on who voters
will decide to elect to represent you
um and Nevada's fourth I'm asking for
your support
that was David charn's reporting